I'm going to state 2442 at the 48
percent shooting Jones Jones taking his
first NBA start for the surprise people
around the NBA by reciting with the
Oklahoma City accent maybe enjoy me with
the bucket
[Applause]
good rebound my Gillett bow left open
the board and the pass by Steph Curry
white jerseys came up with it somehow
it's the presence of mind to see Jonas
Jerebko they hope can fulfill that
stretch for when you get a pass with
next much space they can't all go in ran
down the other end
[Applause]
fancies now into total digital sis cup
the Java Soho
there's a highlight play from Joe Wow
Sam you know in baseball you don't play
it records the number of games are still
considered a rookie
[Applause]
[Music]
Jeff's gonna lop again
[Applause]
finish one more time very good at the
offensive rebound
purify for only seven points the target
really
[Applause]
[Music]
three
when he moved his feet see the skills of
Davis and Durant came to the facility
dr. Krieg
[Applause]
here is curry the lob enjoy the alley to
the first bucket of the game and you see
Steph Curry's willing pass he comes off
he has an open shot turns it down false
is caught in town to respond
the scoring served by Wiggins getting it
done off this green lost on this end
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know what you do when his soul
starts doing that but I love loonie they
finished like a little man with the
underhand scoop thought when he had
nineteen in Chicago which is his
career-high today where he bought his
mom a house in the morning missing 11
straight with a groin injury suffered
originally against Milwaukee in that
blowout Bucs win in Oracle get fined by
curry
hitting Livingston underneath
[Music]
direct KO gifts of cold blood gets the
bounce got a couple of bounces three
BayHawks Jimmy and that's on NBC Sports
Bay Area's it not actually deflect his
Raymont stayed with it this ball is
tipped and that shows me that he's very
alert because it's not fair of this
single lay up in his own right say it
this is a get in shape game we found is
driving along that's it but he felt
LeBron James needed some of these
veterans like Chandler and Stevenson and
Rondo around a lot of pass rough curry
and Iguodala finishes I'm not sure they
don't need to go back to zoo box for
another offensive player in the game
[ __ ] down front ray
what a day for Iguodala 21 points in 18
minutes but I think Rondo so much is
always made of his intelligence that I
don't think enough people concentrated
on his improvement skill wise average
age of 25 stars a year
new a defender might be coming so we
just product quick shot it to lay it in
my mom made him change it maybe wait for
the trailer you can't defend all of that
there's no way see Woody Hayes game I
think it download Mooney knew it
[Applause]
his passing can be equally entertaining
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks behind the play
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ticket Iguodala he knocked away
initially there's one
[Music]
so New Zealand here okay
seven feet
[Music]
step back in the kidney another good
corner 3 and this one he buried he gets
to the line 100 few times at Nazi you
think step tuned-up DeAndre Jordan their
veteran leadership even though he's
taken minutes from these guys these guys
are half their day and they're trying to
make their team they better [ __ ] four
three blasts of Adelphia as the Houston
one wants at 93 a $0 is a little stuff
it to Horford strip Nevada Looney good
defensive play here comes curry
Perry down the middle alley-oop to
Durant beautiful fast-break they go
let's sit back with it to Livingston
gets inside and Shaun Livingston who's
on a nice stretch in recent games puts
Golden State back up by five curry fakes
all rattles a pass to Higginbotham with
one point nine remaining plays on the
offensive end Steph Curry taking the
double-team finding a wide open Andre
Iguodala all by himself for the
beautiful finish warriors about five at
the half
[Music]
Thompson lost his balance curry gives it
up and Iguodala the lane flips it up and
in
largest lead of the night for Golden
State and then another turnover that's
the ninth live ball turnover offered an
air ball Raymond's ahead of everyone
touchdown
the Green has been ejected Heather
Johnson missing that Clay bothered him
play streaking and finishing
walled-off Johnson just enough he kept
an eye on the whole way
alma pass from curry right on the money
you see clay hi Johnson all the way and
doing it at both ends leads the NBA in
steals here's curry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's only a second that's a leap pass
for the curly 4c honest be honest and to
the cool boys been playing hard all
night somebody tell them it's an
all-star game no don't tell them that we
love it pretty plays like it now fight
story all the hot flips to the court
[Applause]
and the two treatments before this you
see Stefan curry
mrs. of three foot six threes in the
game
through that from midcourt
than Finnish long passing just inside
midcourt perfectly thrown sorry trying
to get free curry inside at the time
calls receive mates responsibility to
communicate and let him know it Iguodala
clearly got that off in time
they long green still back in the locker
room feet inside the Bell
nice lob pass to curry its saw that
little note sauce teeth visit their
whose folks inside out is how you create
three since temps dive cut you got clay
the open triple you're just gonna play
through that and they'll shoot better
step little one foot right he saw go got
his own rebound he knew it was missing
and Karev go you mentioned second-chance
points there's another one yes
obviously multiple titles Popovich with
five as a coach Kerr with free and
there's Lodi soaring to the rim twenty
points now on the night he's so good at
getting to his body green all the way to
the rim curry with the assist
[Applause]
I'm gonna tell you right now that's
that's the play of the game house
edition of the quarter high-risk
high-reward shooting well if your
defense can hold true Murray's haven't
River got difficult time getting shots
[Music]
[Applause]
used each terrain berries there for the
rebound
the push
each
[Applause]
haven't we can cement the last what
starting a verb trip against Houston
against loony as he does against cousins
to pace a little more simple mom's gotta
use quickness and he does loony
Livingston and Bogut were 12 of 14 from
the field the ball back
Parsons missing the three and they're
gonna take you for
[Applause]
creates the space but unable to convert
there on that mid-range and how about
that passed by Steph Curry yeah to beat
you these are the little things you talk
about when you want to be successful
[Music]
[Applause]
and it continues as derevko he's got his
own mess trying to spin this fast right
here by step in traffic not even really
looking at Katie yeah and he's got a
variety to his postgame too
he can score over smaller guys hurry the
cousin said cousins were that easy dunk
he decided to get him his touches and
he's this very effective all poles play
put his puppet ain't green left open
again tries
that's another trade down the right
playable saw absolutely good play by
curry
excellent shot by green curry is back
curry on the drive gets it down
come on Lodi has played very well on
easy plays look at curry right there
with the easy driver so he's back in it
just sit on the side and chair no time
for technical other side nice
Vall getting to play call and filing
Beverly out and on the other end his
playoff career I answered Aranda at 45
in Game five big adalat curry back to
Iguodala
Steph Curry but thank you pass to
Iguodala
he does the rest curry gets it to the
paint flips it out a wide open Andre
Iguodala knocks it down there Joe Donlon
how about this performance tonight 13
points off the bench
well it did have an excellent first
absolute ten points and nine rebounds
stuff curry finds draymond Green gets
inside of easy layup it's a great job on
daily impact the game the way that you
can offensive rebound and the fine Eric
goes curry
beautiful think inside once again and
another dunk for the Golden State
Warriors
i knows damn straight
[Applause]
but kidding cush divorce puts the
defense buddies livingstone he just
swiped at the basketball he didn't
retain him Thomas curry its breathe at
the plate he got by rivers and dives in
that's a tall task for anybody
Willard Green releases curry a perfect
pass Green
what an outlet pass from curry off the
rebound falls down
one affects that to me you look like it
was some some pain ladies
throws it down the other end and hood
gets up walking gingerly three four four
already he's got eight points three
catches comes back in for the Portland
Trailblazers curry the drive gets it
inside five assists for curry to go
along with 27 points it's good offense
getting Iguodala involved in it easy
Zack the curry inside hold it Steph
Curry doing a little bit of everything
well they'd like to enter the balls at
green and make him be the playmaker
then fleet on the wrong side of curry
Leonard gets inside misses the layup
curry with another rebound
reverse
playing with pace and curry not to
scoring but finding guys on the
offensive end the previous play McKinney
and this time cook for the easy lands
but that missed by Kawhi Leonard now
repeat inside cousins answers curry to
draymond Green for the puckett what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content